en début de cette édition spéciale
un million et demi de personnes sur les
champs elysées la nuit dernière à paris
on n'avait jamais vu ça
le plus simple pour le résumé c'est de
parler d'une marée bleu blanc rouge
commenté olivier carreau du jamais vu
inclus bientôt admis harry qui exulte
harry qui tient ses libérateurs
un million et demi de personnes sur les
champs elysées nuit blanche
et pour cette marée humaine à défaire le
mot bonheur
il prouve tout le monde les mêmes héros
cette équipe de france où chacun peut
trouver son idole tu m'as pas que nous
la cote de péter quand on est venus ici
en france et pour tous la même bannière
tricolore jusque tôt ce matin disent
qu'une unique de cette coupe du monde
acculé les artères de la capitale